there is sort of just an extraordinary
difference if you're in a place where
you you just feel it's growing versus
not yeah and there there's a sense in
which uh Florida Texas have this um have
this Dynamic of where it's just growing
you know every every storefront is full
there are no empty stores you know
everything it's not I'm not sure it's
quite booming but it feels you know it
feels healthy and growing and then um
and then you know much of California
does not quite have that feel even
though of course you know silicon
Valley's been this odd place where it
was a um you know gold rush and everyone
was depressed yeah even so for the last
decade so the the Silicon Valley had a
very odd Dynamic was a crazy boom that
didn't actually feel that way if you you
know walk down the street
I'm Dave Rubin live from the local
Studio here in Miami and joining me
today is the founder of the teal
Foundation the co-founder of PayPal and
palantir Peter Thiel I could have given
you like a whole bigger intro there
anything else you want to throw in here
it's all good generally the shorter the
intro the more flattering it is yeah
super long you have a 20-page resume for
people who've never done anything so I
was going to say
disgruntled libertarian something the
longer the intro gets the the more it
suggested you're not really doing
anything at all oh all right well you
are doing a lot I have I actually have
notes I never have notes when I do a
show but I was like I want to cover some
new ground and not just get into the the
political thing that we're always
fighting uh with everybody about but I
thought I'd start because we are here in
Miami uh you know you famously left San
Francisco moved most of the operation to
Los Angeles you do have a place in Miami
um how do you feel about this sort of
movement of people across the country
right now and and sort of watching
people migrate to different places to
live very very different ways well it's
uh it's it's it's it's it's truly a very
healthy thing that uh you know it's it's
uh it's in retrospect it's amazing that
people were as stuck as they were in the
places they were they were in for for
such a long time and you know the
history of the US was that this had
always been a society where people moved
a lot between places and and the
mobility
um of physical Mobility had actually
gone down probably a lot for the last 40
or 50 years relative to the you know 200
year history before that and so uh and
you know it's it's probably the jury's
still a little bit out whether this is a
temporary or permanent feature but it's
it's it's surely a healthy recalibration
it's sort of this idea you can always
start over in this country
um and one of the ways you start over is
you move to a new place where you kind
of patting yourself on the back that you
were the first guy out of San Francisco
and my audience is well aware as I've
posted some videos from a recent visit
to San Francisco the way that place has
just collapsed under Progressive
policies is is absolutely insane I'm
guessing you don't have any employees
that are wishing that you guys had
stayed although you still do have some
people there right there still are some
people not not very many that still are
are living in San Francisco uh proper uh
and uh yeah it is it is really
extraordinary I lived I lived in San
Francisco from
2003 to 2000 2018
and it's sort of you know never quite
got better but the idea it took a while
for the Eddie to sneak up on people that
it was actually on the slow Decay
deterioration thing you know the
homelessness was always a chronic
problem but in circa 2014 2015 you
started to realize you know it's
actually getting worse and they're never
gonna it's not just that this is this
fake problem that they're taking a long
time to fix it's they are it's a fake
problem they use to distract from
everything else they're never going to
fix it so when you when you're here it's
also a real problem well it's also right
it's it's clearly a real problem but
something that they either don't seem
interested in fixing well what do you
think
what they're not interested there are a
lot of problems that are both real and
fake yeah so the homeless problem is you
know yeah it's a it's a it's an
incredible problem but um it's also you
get a sense that it never gets fixed and
so if you if you talk about a problem
that you're never going to fix then you
can avoid talking about all the other
problems like let's say cost of living
for
um out of control rents for people with
homes or broken schools or you know
crime or you know there's sort of are
probably half a dozen other issues that
uh move to the bottom of the queue as
long as we talk about an unsolvable
problem when you were there were you
trying to talk to them about those
things and say guys like look at what is
happening here and and and the state of
the Decay well on the on the on the city
level it felt it felt like uh exit is
much more powerful than voice yeah you
know it is uh it was uh I'm not sure
it's super corrupt but uh uh San
Francisco is super ideological In This
Very left-wing very uh unreformable way
and uh and uh no it would be you know
it's it's I always have a schizophrenic
view about getting involved in in
politics where it's like super important
and super toxic but uh but getting
involved in San Francisco San Francisco
city politics uh that would be that
would be absolutely an insane thing to
do relative to just moving you're not
enough of a masochist for that it's it's
uh you know I'm I'm heroism's good
martyrdom not so good and uh and uh and
yeah the the relative uh the relative
sanity of getting involved in local
politics or just moving out of San
Francisco you should always move so to
that point one more thing on this uh so
now you're here in Florida you know you
have a place
so you're split in time and obviously
you also have your place in LA but do
you feel a real tangible difference when
you're here I mean you know I left a
year ago and it's like I have not looked
back and I'm loving it here and I see
something so incredibly uh powerful and
flourishing here do you feel that when
you're here uh well it has you know
there is there is sort of just an
extraordinary difference if you're in a
place where where you just feel it's
growing versus not yeah and there
there's a sense in which uh Florida
Texas have this um have this Dynamic of
where it's just growing you know every
every storefront is full there are no
empty stores you know everything it's
not I'm not sure it's quite booming but
it feels you know it feels healthy and
growing and then um and then you know
much of California does not quite have
that feel even though of course you know
silicon Valley's been this odd place
where it was a um you know gold rush and
everyone was depressed yeah even so for
the last decade so the the Silicon
Valley had a very odd Dynamic was a
crazy boom that didn't actually feel
that way if you you know walk down the
street and then uh and then certainly
with the Kobe chalk the last few years
uh it's quite different I still think
California is is probably somewhat
healthier than New York or you know
completely bankrupt States like Illinois
or you know non-states like Puerto Rico
why do you think healthier than New York
I think um I think the I think there are
ways that the the finance industry that
New York is centered on is more movable
than the tech industry in California
and probably the very big tech companies
like Google and Apple
it's it's hard to picture them actually
moving out of California whereas you can
you can pick you can picture the big
Banks gradually moving out of New York
and certain and and there's something
about Finance that's been a little bit
more movable it also paradoxically makes
it more dangerous for California because
um if things ever go wrong
they will be so bust really like it'll
be like Detroit which thought that it
had these captive big three car
manufacturers and uh could get away with
very bad policies in Michigan Detroit
for decade after decade and then when
you know when that industry finally went
South you know it was it was just
unflexible so do you find that New York
New York's in a worse shape right now
because people are are you know
relatively more people are leaving it's
easier for the businesses to leave
um and then maybe maybe California if it
if it's not careful you know it will at
some point really go off the cliff right
do you find that these things sort of
happen slowly and then very quickly so
something like California it's like you
know Cali's lost almost a million people
in these last three years and a lot of
them are high earners I mean these are
people who are paying into the system
that's ever growing at some point
somebody has to look at numbers right
and be like none of this works or I
guess maybe not right it just continues
somehow I suppose yeah I I actually I
don't know how many of them were the
highest earners in California the last
last years I think New York was was a
little bit more or that effect than than
California but yes these things you know
we have these odd Dynamics where things
go on for a very long time they're not
ultimately sustainable but you know you
know there's some there's some way I
often think that much of the 2000s and
2010s
were this weird continuation of the
1990s you know the decades there were
things that happened you know at 9 11
you had the global financial crisis
Trump election brexit there were some
events that happened in those 20 years
but it was surprisingly little December
2019 I was reflecting on the 2010s and I
I realized there have been no
retrospectives on this decade what
actually happened in the 2010s you know
we had marijuana legalization we had
Game of Thrones and people fell into
their iPhones and uh and then uh but
then it was somehow just this this thing
that was sort of a stretched exhausted
version of the 2000s which themselves
were stretch exhausted version of the
90s and then uh and then I yeah I want
to say that in some sense you know March
2020 when cobit hits
um we finally you know uh a lot of these
things finally accelerate and so and you
know um and uh we're finally in the 21st
century if you're looking for a more
unfiltered lens into the World of
Tomorrow check out our Tech playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a wide variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of future videos be sure
to subscribe and click the notification
Bell